-Welcome back, guys.
It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out
a hashtag and ask you guys to
respond to that topic.
So, since the finale of
"The Bachelorette"
was this week, I sent out
the hashtag...
And I asked you to tweet --
oh, get ready --
tweet your funny or embarrassing
first-date stories.
Within minutes, it was a
trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
I appreciate it.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#WorstFirstDate
tweets from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's from
@elise millsssss. She says...
[ Sneezes ]
"God bless me. Thank me.
I'm welcome."
Wow! That's a lot.
-Yeah.
-This one is from @nameisamber.
She says...
I like that line.
"I hope he's doing well."
She never saw him again, yeah.
This one's from @Luchill.
She says...
An ax.
[ Laughs ]
-Not a baseball bat.
-Wow!
-Not a ball bat, an ax.
-I got to be honest.
If I was a thief and I walked in
and some dude had an ax,
I'd just leave.
-I'd go, "I'm not gonna take --
Hey, guess what.
You can keep the stereo.
I'm gonna buy --"
-I learned a lesson today.
-Yeah.
-I learned a lesson. We're good.
-I didn't know an ax
was coming at me.
-Yeah, I didn't know you
were gonna have
an ax next to your bed.
-I didn't know I broke into
Paul Bunyan's house.
-It's my ax-boyfriend.
-Oh!
That's my body spray.
-I got to write these down.
-Yeah, I got my body spray.
-This one's from @Jenn2NsReese.
She says...
-Ooh!
Oh!
-Gross!
-He's got an ax in his trunk.
-Yeah. Yeah.
He traveled -- That dude
traveled with an ax, yeah.
This one is from @kaytang41.
She says...
♪♪
You like that?
-That takes -- that's class.
-You'd do that? You'd do that?
-You've done that?
-You can't do it on
a first date, though.
-No.
I remember my mom would
sneak stuff into
the theater all the time.
Like, all --
We'd watch the movie.
All of a sudden, you'd hear,
like, a 2-liter bottle go...
[ Hisses ]
-We would hide in the trunk
at the drive-in.
-Yeah, she's, like,
grilling a hamburger. Yeah.
"How do you want
your hamburger done?"
"You can't bring
a grill in here."
-It's a hibachi.
-"It's a hibachi.
It's not a grill."
This one's from @cameronpfink.
He said...
-He's the worst first date.
-Yeah, yeah.
I didn't understand this one.
I thought he was on a date
that said they were
related to Theodore Roosevelt.
-Oh, he -- But he said he was
related to Theodore --
-He actually lied
and said that he was
related to Theodore Roosevelt,
then excused himself to
the washroom to Google facts
about Theodore Roosevelt
to make it sound like
he knew what he was
talking about.
So he was --
-He's the worst-first-date guy.
-In fact, he was actually
the worst first date.
What?
-The New York Police Force was
founded by Theodore Roosevelt.
And his house on Oyster Bay?
-Yes, of course. Of course.
No real relationship to
Franklin Roosevelt.
-His cousin, and, actually,
Eleanor was also a cousin.
because they were
both named R-R-R-Roosevelt.
-Roosevelt. R-R-R-Roosevelt.
-Have you seen my ax?
-Aah!
♪♪
This one's from @Cilla Thornton.
She says...
-Oh!
♪♪
Not one.
-What in the world?
-Not one.
-The world is amazing.
They say chivalry --
they say chivalry is dead.
-Yeah. Chivalry lives long.
-"No."
-TMI.
-One in the sty.
-This one's from @Shonje 7.
She says...
-Oh!
♪♪
Slam dunk!
[ Sad tuba plays ]
"I think this is yours."
-Wow!
It's not -- it's not.
-It's not. Oh, my gosh.
Oh, it's mine. Sorry.
-This last one is --
That is just disgusting.
-From his denture, too.
-Yeah.
-Wasn't a real tooth even.
-Oof!
-Fake tooth to begin with.
-Just the whole thing.
Just I can't even
think about it.
This last one's from
@CarolineMilyard. She said...
There you have it.
That's romantic.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.